hi everyone thanks for staying to the
end of the day I want to talk about an
algorithmic framework to solve Beijing
mechanism design problems this is based
on joint where was Madeline Costas so
this framework developed during a line
of research happen past few years to me
there are two motivating questions for
this line of research first one is one
has been raised in the previous two
talks namely how can you design revenue
optimal auction when you have multi
vitamins for sell the second question is
more high-level question our more
general it was raised by Nissan aronan
basically they were asking how much more
difficult is mechanism design are
converting to algorithm design okay i
want to show you today that our
framework provides some understanding on
both questions okay let me start with
the first one so i think everyone here
knows my sins auction so let me just
quickly remind you what his auction
looks like it's a bitter submit their
bits and they're transforming to some
virtual bits then the item is given to
the one who has a highest virtue bit in
this case six okay and after morrisons
result there has been a large body will
work from economics trying to generalize
his results to more general settings but
unfortunately no general
characterization is no a recently
computer science is starting to look at
this problem we provided many
approximation algorithms in fact the
previous two talks actually provide two
approximation algorithms sorry I didn't
include them here but in this talk what
I want to do is I'll just show you an
algorithm that actually computes the
optimal mechanism exact mechanism in
efficient manner for a very general
setting what I want to point out is by
looking at this problem from an
algorithmic proper perspective we
actually managed to characterize the
structure of the optimal action
in particular when the bitter set out of
this which is deciding let's look in the
previous two talks the optimal auction
has a very similar structure as
meyerson's okay bidders the submit their
bits these bits are transformed into
some virtual bids now for each item I
will give the item to the one who has
the highest virtue bit for that
particular item okay in this case I'll
give Apple to myself because I have six
that's the highest bid for Apple and
same for orange okay this is very
similar to myosins auction except that
in Mars this case the transformation is
given by some closed form function and
salsa deterministic in this case the
transformation is randomized and
computed by someone in your program I
want to emphasize that we know examples
where the optimal auction needs to be
randomized so that's a sort of a that's
basically what i want to say for the
results about the first question give
more details later let me move to the
second question okay in the second
question I want to understand how more
that much more difficult as mechanism
design compared to algorithm design okay
in algorithm design or usually faced
with the following problem you're giving
some input you're asked to design some
algorithm that does some operation on
the input and produces some desire
outcome okay in mechanism design the
picture is very similar except that the
input is usually given by some agents
and the bad news for the algorithm
designer is the agents actually care
about the output of the algorithm they
have some key interest here if your
album is not designed carefully they
might miss report input and get better
payoff for themselves but the point here
is if your inputs wrong the app is not
going to be meaningful so mechanism
basically it's an algorithm that that is
robust to such strategy behavior
so in seminal paper by Nissan aronan
they ask if you have an optimization
problem how much more difficult is the
corresponding mechanism design problem
that's what I mean when you have a
strategy input for a problem compared to
the algorithm design problem where you
have an honest input and in my mind the
best solution you can hope for for this
problem is a black box reduction that
reduces mechanism and mechanism designed
to algorithm design for any optimization
problem so what do I mean by that so you
have some optimization problem and say
you have an algorithm to solve this
optimization problem now what I want is
some mechanism that solves the same
optimization problem okay what I want to
have is some procedure that interacts
with the agents also it interacts with
this algorithm by a few rounds of
interaction this procedure figures out
what to output and if this procedure
only queries this algorithm as some
Oracle this will become a black box
reduction okay and why do I care about
black box reduction there are few
reasons the arguably in the community of
a computer spherical computer science
more snow about algorithms comparing two
mechanisms so if you have such a
reduction that means maybe some
mechanism design problem which are
unsolved can be just reduced to some
problems in algorithm design which
already soft and also this allows a
larger community to tackle important
problems mechanism design because now
the problem is completely is purely
algorithmic you don't even need to know
mechanism design you can just stop the
problem algorithmic problem and the last
point I want to make here is I think
such a reduction can provide some deep
understanding of mechanism design namely
why is incentive so hard to deal with
so in this talk informally I want to say
that such a reduction exist if we have
seen many black box reductions many of
the famous mechanisms you can view them
as reductions okay so if you want to
optimize social offer the famous VCG
mechanism optimize welfare in any
setting I want to think about I think of
the VCG mechanism as a reduction so
namely they reduce the mechanism prior
design problem for optimized social
welfare to the following algorithmic
problem you just find an allocation that
maximize the sum of everyone's value for
the allocation if you can solve this
algorithmic problem you can also run BCG
okay and in a recent line of research it
was shown that there is a black box
reduction that can accommodate
approximation when your objective
function in social welfare okay so it
means if you can solve this algorithmic
problem approximately you can also
optimize social over approximately okay
and turns out if you want to optimize
revenue the margins auction can also
give you as a reduction so the bitter
submitter bits this bits are
transforming to some virtual bits then
you can think of these you can think of
the mechanisms is feeding these virtual
bits to some algorithm that just finds
the largest number or saying you find
the maximum welfare allocation with
respect to this virtual bits okay that's
meyerson's auction so obviously obvious
question you want to ask is okay for a
welfare we have black box reduction we
have single item we have black box
reduction what if you have multi
vitamins you want to optimize revenue
you have general valuation function can
you see you have black box reduction or
you want to go beyond revenue and Social
Welfare you want some general objective
for example we want to minimize the
makespan of job scheduling or say you
care about maximum fairness can you see
you half of a black box reduction
first I want to show you that if your
objective functions revenue you can
always reduce the mechanism design
problem it's an algorithmic problem
that's just maximizing virtual welfare
okay and when your objective function is
some it's more general there's actually
some known barrier due to a shuchi unico
and Brendan they showed that if your
objective functions Oh for the mechanism
design problem there is no black box
reduction that reduces to an algorithmic
problem for the same objective but what
i want to show you today is you can
reduce the mechanism design problem to
an algorithmic problem that optimizes
the same objective plus or virtual
welfare term ok so what do I mean by
that so formally if you want to design a
mechanism that optimize some objective
oh it's enough for you to have some
algorithm that optimizes the same
objective Oh plus and virtue offer and
the reduction works in polynomial time
ok so here this algorithm will optimize
objective function with respect to the
reported types and plus a welfare term
that's with respect to some virtual
types that's what i mean by virtue over
here if you have an algorithm that
optimizes the sum you can construct a
mechanism that optimizes objective oh ok
I want to point out here that the
reduction cannot calm the approximation
if you can just approximately optimize
the sum here you can still approximately
optimize oh and the reduction preserves
exactly you have the same exact you have
exactly the same approximation factor so
to me the way to interpret this result
is saying if you want to go from one is
input to strategy input it is no more
difficult computationally than just
adding a virtual welfare term to your
objective function
so next I want to give you an overview
of our framework and i'll use the amount
ahmadi item auction as running example
so this is essentially the same setting
yeah and Matt talked about so you have
NM for sell you have em bidders thorough
additive okay the bidders valuation
bitter eyes valuations straw from some
no distribution di I want to emphasize
that the main difference between this
result and the result is the values here
may be correlated your value for item
one island three might be correlated but
in their case it's mostly assumed to be
independent okay and also you want to
assume designer in other agents no VI
this is a very common assumption the
goal here is you want to design a
truthful mechanism that optimizes
revenue in expectation and by truthful
by true Salinas I mean patients and
compatible for people who are not
familiar with this concept this means if
everyone else is telling the truth I
prefer to tell choice as well yeah our
or biology independent across buyers yes
so we relaxed so you have a correlation
right your correlation across items per
your independent consommateurs
just want to remind you this is the same
setting that I show you the structure
result will have efficient algorithms
were finding a revenue optimal auction
and the auction has a very similar
structure as Myers's okay so how do you
prove such a result so in a very high
level sense I want to use an LP to
search for the optimal auction okay so
to do that I need the variables to
describe an auction okay I need some
variables describe allocation
probabilities I need some variables to
describe prices after that I want to
make sure these variables actually
describe an auction that is truthful so
I need some truthfulness constraints
also i need to make sure these variables
actually corresponds to a real mechanism
so i also have some feasibility
constraints and the objective is obvious
i want to maximize the expected revenue
so turns out there is a very full all
way to write an LP so the variables will
be the following so I described the
probability that item J is allocated to
bitter I when the type profiles t okay i
call this phi j of t i also have a TI t
to describe the price that better i pays
under type roboti okay so these are
usually known as expose allocation rule
so now i can write the trismus
constraint using the variables the
reason i can write write these
constraints as linear equalities over
the variables is because from these
variables I know my expected utility if
my true type is t by my rims report to
be t / t prime this is just a linear
function over the variables if you can
do that you can write these two
constraints as linear equalities okay
and also it's easy to check whether are
these variables correspond to a feasible
mechanism all you need to do is to make
sure no item is allocated out more than
once so you want to check for all
possible type profiles all items sum
over all bidders to phi j of t is no
larger than 1 if that's the case your
feasible okay
and the objective functions just expect
just expected revenue so if you can
solve this LP I find the optimal action
okay but there are some issues the first
one is this LP it's just too big its
enormous if you compute the number or if
you calculate the number of variables a
number of constraints you realize that
both our polynomial and the total number
of type profiles which is exponential in
your input ok so there's just no hope
for me to solve this awesome but even
say for a very small instance I can stop
this I don't get any structure of the
optimal auction all I see is a laundry
list on what to do for every type
profile I don't I don't get any
structure understanding ok so as an
alternative I want to describe this meka
describe an option in a more succinctly
so I use the interim allocation rule
also know as reduced forms to describe
an auction ok so I have a variable co-pi
JPI that specifies the following
probability condition on my type is di
what so probably the item J is allocated
to me in expectation over everyone
else's type and also the randomness of
the auction ok and similarly i define a
payment p I of T I is expected payment
for me when my type is TI and my
expected payment and sorry my payment in
expectation over everyone else's type
and they're not random soph the auction
okay so it's not hard to see that if
this is the way I describe the auction
only need a polynomial in the number of
filter types variables where previously
i need to total number of type profiles
so this saves me a lot and this is just
wrong number and type the size of the
input
sorry going to assume that this this
probabilities for the different chaser
in the fender here I say my different
chick no not particularly yeah
I think that will show up if I want to
check visible it later but not here so
with reduced forms i can write a 16 LP
so this should reduce one will be the
variables i can write the truthfulness
constraint steel although i'd the
reduced one is much such thing a much
more sexting description of the auction
i'll still be able to figure out my
expected utility when my true type is t
pirate misreport tip I ok so here the
left-hand side says if my true type is
TI that's probably I'm getting this
vector that's probably I'm getting each
item that's my private value for each
item so the whole dot dot product is
just my expected value when my true type
is TI and I report the guy this is my
expected payment so the whole offense is
just my expected utility when I'm being
truthful and my type is di ok the
right-hand side says if I missed report
my type too BTW i prime but my true type
is TI this is my expected utility so
this constraint is just saying being
truthful is better than I ok this has
exactly the Christmas constraint the
objective function is to you just expect
the revenue i can write as a linear
function over the variables so now the
main difficulty here is how do i enforce
the reduced form to be feasible ok so
turns out you cannot enforce a reduced
form to be feasible just using a few
number linear constraints so challenge
will be how can you verify if a reduced
form actually corresponds to real
mechanism ok in other word can i have a
separation oracle that checks the
feasibility of the reduced one
turns out this is a quite well study
problem in economics it was first study
in the 80s then water came along and
show that if you have a single item
reduced for there exists a set of linear
constraints that characterize the
feasibility of these reduced forms okay
later check in Miranda provided a more
convenient or approved based on max flow
min cut but the problem here is i still
cannot just add these set of linear
constraints to my LP because there's two
exponential many okay so what we did and
independently all had the same result we
provide equivalent conditions that can
be checked in polynomial time so that
will give you a computationally
efficient version of Euler's theorem and
turns out in the additive setting or do
you have multiple items to check
visibility of your reduced form you
really just need to look at for each
item whether it reduce form is feasible
or not if that's feasible the whole are
reduced form is feasible so I'll average
of a single item voters theorem we can
check visibility in this case
so where are we let me remind you the
big picture so in the first step I write
a six ting LP using the reduced forms as
other variables in the second step I
used borders theorem as a separation or
go to check visibility so not going to
solve this sexting LP and find the
optimal reduce foreign PI star ok but
I'm not done yet because all I have now
is just the optimal reduced one if you
give me a type profile I don't know what
to do that's not real mechanism so I
still need an efficient way to map a
reduced form back to an allocate expose
allocation rule ok turns out the full
and characterization theorem would prove
this very useful so we first show that
if you look at the set of radius worms
it's going to form a polytope ok this is
very easy to prove next we show that if
you're looking at a corner of these
polytope there exists some virtual value
function f if you use the allocation
route that maximizes virtual value
respect to f the corresponding reduced
form will be that corner so in other
words we prove that any corner of these
polytope can be implemented as a virtual
welfare Maximizer ok so if you combine
this characterization theorem with the
result back our third re then you can
see that the optimal reduced form is
simply a convex combination over corners
that can be implemented as virtual
welfare maximizers ok particularly that
means the optimal mechanism itself is
just a distribution over virtual of your
maximizers ok so every corner in this
compass combination will give you a
different virtual value function your
mechanism which is simple this virtual
one virtual value function according to
this convex combination and then find
the
occasion to maximize stuff okay so here
I completed a proof for the added buyer
setting okay now i want to show you that
if you want to go to general settings
what do you need to change in the the
whole framework okay so when you have
that is buyers in the first step your
right and i'll be using the reduced
forms turns out in general settings
reduced forms are not meaningful you
need to use some other implicit interim
description of the mechanism okay and in
the second step i use borders veeram
when you have when parameters are
additive buddha serum doesn't work when
you have more general types but luckily
we can use the fingers to sell
equivalents of separation optimization
by a virtual over shriver and appending
a carp and papa Demetriou to get a
separation article using just black box
assess to some algorithm that optimizes
the objective plus virtual offer okay so
i can still solve the LP to get the
optimal implicit interim description now
i need to implement it as real mechanism
okay in the address by our case i know
the optimal the optimal mechanism can be
implemented as a description
distribution over virtue of your
maximizers it turns out the same
characterization theorem still holds
when you have valuation functions beyond
additive if you try to optimize revenue
it's just that your virtual types are
more complicated okay but if you want to
optimize some other objective the
characterization theorem becomes the
optimal mechanism is the distribution
over virtue objective maximizers in
particular in this form okay
so that's the frame how the frame one
looks like in the general setting okay
so I want to talk about some other
extensions we have for this framework so
we managed to accommodate approximation
in our framework so as a result you can
use our framework to handle auction
settings with heart budget constraint or
you have reversion bidders and also you
can go beyond auctions for example you
if we want to minimize mix meant for
scheduling jobs or maximum fairness our
framework with some modification you can
use our framework to get mechanisms that
matches the state of our approximation
factors
now let me come back to the two
motivated questions I have in the
beginning so Marcin show that if you
have a single dimensional setting the
revenue optimum oxygen is just a virtual
warfare Maximizer we show that no matter
what the bidders types are the revenue
optimal auction can always be described
as a distribution over virtue of your
maximizers okay and again this is
discovered by looking at this problem
from an algorithmic perspective of all
the second question I want to understand
how much more difficult is mechanism
design compared to algorithm design so I
show you that if you're intubation
setting you can always have a black box
reduction that reduces mechanism
designed to algorithm design so in other
words it means if you want to go from
honest input to strategy input this is
no more difficult computational than
just adding this virtual welfare term to
your objective
this is my last slide so I will just say
that after marcin's work that has been
so much development in single
dimensional settings and if at all so
some related multi-dimensional settings
so our framework provides some new tools
for looking at mounted dimensional
settings so what can we do with that so
we already seen some application of this
framework for objective functions beyond
revenue and Social Welfare and also to
accommodate budgets in your auction
setting but hopefully this is just the
beginning and there are more for us to
explore it's really thing also a short
advertisement this is very short version
of this framework I'll be giving a
three-hour whiteboard talk in the end of
this month I 30th no Nova 30th so if
you're interested come to this long
version October ok October 3ds any
questions
so you're setting up a large in a
program that has to do with the number
of some of the number of different types
in many setting stars come in some real
numbers can you say anything about some
natural way of either solving the expert
that continuously larger fee or
discretizing in some under some
assumption or something so thick fur
elise for the eyes starting up I've
talked about you can discretize sir
you're in the form say your continuous
in 01 say okay I can discretize the type
space and get an optimal and
approximately optimal auction but also
need to pay apps no interest on this so
I get a personal pic
depends a house more discretized also
the characterization folks book yet our
position is a hopeful continues yeah but
if you discretize you lasted two yes you
know the protractor ization you don't
need to dicker ties continue sending
what can you get actually defined what
you meant by virtual values analysis as
you were putting it up I was the
incentive constraints of course every
year their contacts you can always use
the Lagrangian to the objective function
f if you're upset
so I think in some sense you're right so
if you look around to find some
constraints and you look at the longer a
locker and refined multipliers in the
optimal solution and that will
correspond to the virtual values I'm
talking about or some linear combination
of those Lagrangian multipliers will
correspond to the virtuality I'm talking
about I'm not claiming this the same as
Martha you just need to say you don't
have the revenue eCos virtual welfare
here I'm just saying you're up and what
our auction looks like the form that
you're maximizing some virtual value
function something x I again is that
there's a global ordering of all the
types and basically the corners response
to our learning about ordering every
item goes to the highest type that shows
that is reported but and so for each
item then is a global ordering of all
the types now when you choose a corner
you just ironing that ordering for each
item they give the added to the highest
type in the indie ordering so that it in
some sense the virtual values of
different corners have arbitrary but
they are related it's just one till
about ordering above the sides or every
a hit away from over for each other but
it's updating yeah all the types of a
repeater the item is given to the hyatt
for each item the highest type that
shows up for the ordering of that item
so with the reason I ask this question
here with me
constraints feasibility constraints are
just a [ __ ] once in combinatorial we
also found that related the different
that the optimum think that maximizes
the sellers sellers Kostas option to
purchase involve maximizing or
minimizing a virtual virtual cost for
maximizing the virtual retinal
accelerator more complicated constraints
just you know that a number of items
constraints or nothing that's why I was
thinking that they either thinking in
terms of the Lagrangian the incentive
constraints is moving up your anything
with the disability constraints except
there even if that are horrible and
still have a characterization so exactly
for if you have like complicated
physically constraint you can do what
you set so i think what causes is saying
if you have in this simple setting you
don't have complicated physically
constrain you can just allocate the item
flipper you wants you have this ordering
of the types
she said the one algorithmic take away
is that the mechanism design problem is
no harder than solving like a different
algorithmic problem the original
objective plus the burka welfare is that
generally harder thanked all right are
there problems for which to that problem
is intractable with the optimization
government open up so uh we know that if
you have some module evaluation you want
to optimize revenue even for one bidder
you have both way so if you cannot you
should we can show that that's the only
way you can optimize to revenue and
turns out you can argue that because the
algorithmic problem is hard and that's
the only way to do it so optimize
revenue is hard okay so there are some
settings we know it goes both ways in
general it's we don't know so to jump
did we mention that you give the same
results as know what is that mean we get
to but you're comparing to the optimal
patient set of compatible mechanism not
the optimal algorithmic solution the
factor sector is to sort of em so to
work in the pager in the base register